hey good
[ __ ] news
[Music]
yes that's right uh our favorite segment
is back he's he's back he's working
again
he's working again thank God glad to
have him back Michaels yeah get his dad
died dealing with some [ __ ]
so
um well I'll let George Stephanopoulos
angrily introduce the segment Michael a
lot more from your interview with Prince
Harry that's right George you know we
got a one-hour interview with Prince
Harry I spoke and had a one-on-one with
the Royal ahead of the release one of
the Mr Stephanopoulos this [ __ ] this
goddamn piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] the real family has blown me off
like 30 times [ __ ] this
spoke about and with the Riff with his
brother Prince William and what is
Mother Princess Diana would think
how would he know what his mother would
think
huh
because the last thing she thought was
like oh my God hit the brakes
take a look
through Princess Diana's mind was her
ass
[Laughter]
so we thought talking about the problems
he had with his brother well half
brother technically Danny half brother
now why you dress up like a Nazi
overnight what a gay book what a gay
book by a gay guy new details emerging
from Prince Harry's Memoir spare after
the book incorrectly went on sale in
Spain ahead of its official yeah you
know why because you're the spare Prince
you're the backup unless your [ __ ]
brother dies you're never gonna be king
yeah you're the backup quarterback it's
no coincidence you look like Andy Dalton
yeah you're the donut spare in the back
of a rental car now you don't get a
full-size one
God you little 20 incher yeah exactly
official release Tuesday media outlets
around the globe pouring over every word
in an excerpt obtained by People
magazine Harry recalling a visit to
Paris in 2007. his life seems so tough
where he says he retraced his mother
Princess Diana's steps the night she
died I had to [ __ ] three dudes but it
was worth it
[Laughter]
that's clean [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I [ __ ]
myself there
hmm Harry driving through the tunnel his
mother was killed in asking his driver
to go the same speed she was traveling
this is [ __ ] why
what a dramatic little [ __ ] this guy is
right what a girl what a mo you are
his wife bro
miles per hour Harry reportedly writing
quote as the car enters the tunnel I
leaned forward counted my heartbeats and
in a few seconds we emerged from the
other side I sat back you were in
Afghanistan
quietly I said is that all of it it's
nothing just a straight tunnel no reason
anyone should ever die inside it is he
doing the conspiracy theory thing
he's made you know what he know he is no
no no no because if Trump would do this
like pandering to cure or whatever but
Trump's pandering to kill he's pandering
to the people that think that they had
her killed and that really the day
wasn't really an accident in the tunnel
you know that's a conspiracy right these
are tremendous tennis folks best tunnels
in the world frankly I don't know how
somebody could have died in there
exactly that's what he's doing
the prince said the after driver to go
through again and then he said to go in
and out like a cartoon when they're
showing sex
describing how a decade after her death
that drive Unleashed a new wave of grief
reportedly writing quote I used to be a
man and then I married TV doctor
yeah and she sucked all the testosterone
out of me but not in the good way um
it had been a very I think she's
crushing up soy in my cereal she's doing
something pretty bad idea I told myself
that I wanted closure but I didn't
really deep down I'd hoped to feel
disbelief doubt instead that was the
night all doubt fell away imagine saying
something like I had my driver
drive through a tunnel a couple times
like and still try to be like we were
victims you had a driver you just had a
driver
the only driver I have has Uber in front
of it
wait she's dead I thought my God she's
really gone for good other outlets
reporting on the Riff with his brother
Prince William the guardian detailing at
alleged physical confrontation between
the sibling you got to feel bad for
Prince William because here's the thing
they [ __ ] his hair he lost his hair
really young right and I can relate to
that well yeah because he's Prince
Charles's kid but honestly he's not a
bad look if you put hair on him he's not
a bad looking guy well he was a good
looking girl right that's my point
that's really young but like when he was
like 18 and they would cover it on TV he
was a good looking kid I remember
because I've known merch for a while he
would call him that sexy sexy kid all
the time it was weird God man that that
[ __ ] Williams such a sexy kid he had
a countdown clock for his 18th birthday
like you said for the Olsen twins
but dude it's so obvious that this other
one is [ __ ] the tennis Pro's kid yeah
obviously he looks just like he looks
just like him
explains in 2019. Harry reportedly
writing William quote grab me by the
collar ripping my necklace and knocked
me to the floor in a new interview
airing on GMA Monday I I realized he was
a little taller than I expected
I asked Prince Harry about their
complicated relationship how would your
mom feel about your relationship now
which one are you on the chess board the
horsey one I'm not really I'm new with
this are you the little castle or the
horse I don't know which one you are
which direction can you walk in do you
go diagonal or do you go let me forward
and then one to the left or right
that's his only asking about chest it's
your brother now what's up with them
giant black Q-tip hats that's the gods
wear yeah is that a joke or something
or is it so they clean the uh the
ceilings and it does the cobwebs as they
walk are your soldiers Coneheads trying
to hide their identity
I think she would be sad
well would you be alive I think she'd be
looking at looking at it long term to
know that there are certain things that
we need to go through to be like a bunch
of tennis players able to heal the
relationship and in order to do that I
uh married a black woman who stood a lot
of drama in my family and became a bit
of a [ __ ]
a cigarette
um I have felt the presence of my mum
more so in the last two years than I
have of course ever since he ever since
he met the the woman the evil woman that
gets in your ear
and starts doing like I don't know I
mean I think maybe they killed your mom
honey did you ever think about that
which I probably did but you know no but
I know but she's just stirring it you
know
have in the last 30. we don't call it
chess around these parts by the way if
somebody says ROTC chest humor it's hard
Checkers you know even the only 12 years
old when his mother passed away but you
can still see the influence that she's
had on his life and and the reason why
if it was literally if Michael Strahan
spends the entire interview talking
about how his dad just died oh my God
this is that [ __ ] dominates the
conversation
well I mean I know but you lost your mom
you know that was like 30 years ago and
I just lost my dad so you know I'm
suffering more probably can somebody
explain to me what Princess Diana did
besides [ __ ] a bunch of dudes and be
pretty that everyone loves her so much
now I'm trying to understand what did
she do honestly I'm not because I don't
get I never get [ __ ] about the rules
maybe I'm missing something I'm not even
trying to be so please tell me
legitimately what she did that earned
her so much Fame because she was pretty
that she really wasn't even all that
yeah so I really don't understand what
she did she was a propaganda piece like
this was back when you know we didn't
have as many channels we didn't have the
internet
it was like ooh the royal family no one
made you marry that old [ __ ] Royal
[ __ ] either you did it on purpose you
know
she was basically the last Royal that
like everyone gave a [ __ ] about before
like the internet started and people
started actually like questioning why
the royal family even exists somebody
said was she even that pretty for a
royal she was I'm not no from like not
for normal people someone you know but
she touched AIDS patients yeah well
[ __ ] so did faucier when he went to
the gay clubs who cares
she didn't touch any toilet seats I
heard that's how you get it
incredible doctor told me that went
through that tunnel that he realized she
was gone because he had pretty much
played a game with himself to say she's
only in hiding and then she'll come back
for me and my brother one day
well he's he's insane
he's insane but he's dealing with a lot
of a lot of trauma a lot of grief and
and he's sharing it all in the book yeah
yeah he put it all in the book and the
books could have got to help sell this
book and the book's gonna be for free
right
one main goal here and it's the only job
we had to help sell this book because
we're part of a media conglomerate that
also owns a large stake in the book
publisher they said Michael those those
Flats Antarctica are free we got to pay
for them somehow yeah you want to ever
see them puffins again they actually
capture four or five of my Puffin
friends said they kill him with the book
doesn't sell at least a million copies I
can't let him kill the puffins I can't
so I'm gonna I'm gonna sacrifice them
and push this book just to save these
puffins
back to you George I'm right here I'm
we're in the same room Michael you don't
need to say back to you
and spare is out Tuesday and you can see
my interview with Prince Harry Monday on
GMA and streaming on Hulu I I probably
we will be watching that I'm sure I'm
sure that that is something we will be
covering because I need to hear these
amazing questions thank you Michael we
are very glad that you're back well
what's it like owning a crown
I've been to Burger King once but my
head too big and the crown don't fit
uh question didn't know in the old days
they will provide horses do you guys
still have horses Rockingham Palace
um I always wanted a horse but my wife
said you can't get no horsey you got
kids you can't be falling off no horse
leaving the kids fatherless she wouldn't
let me get a horse or a motorcycle
anyway what was I talking about